rénovation des gares nouvelles dessertes
pour les scolaires autopartage la
communauté d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines poursuit sa
politique de transport éco citoyenne
afin de permettre à tous de se déplacer
dans un esprit de développement durable
petit tour d'horizon avec un dossier qui
va vous transporter à tout prix
faciliter les déplacements des saint
quentinois est l'une des priorités de la
communauté d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines facile à dire
mais pas toujours aisée à mettre en
place alors en cette rentrée quelles
sont les nouveautés et quelles sont les
priorités
et oui on est comme ça nous on pose des
questions la rentrée va être mis sous le
sceau donc de la desserte scolaire un
travail très important a été mené par la
direction des transports de manière à
jus localiser l'ensemble les élèves de
l'agglomération
on a fortement à milan les choses en
améliorant
la desserte les amplitudes et ses 140
élèves de plus ils pourront voir à la
rentrée bénéficier d'une offre
performante de bus pour se rendre dans
cet accident
concernant les travaux il concerne
effectivement dans une large mesure le
secteur du pôle gare de 51 ans des
travaux débutent à partir d'octobre sur
la place le theux c'est une première
phase qui série des travaux qui vont
s'échelonner sur le secteur concernant
la salle des pas perdus la venue de
l'équipe de la sncf est un ensemble de
travaux également son concours comme les
habitants ont pu constater les premières
livraisons de boutiques ou avoir lieu
d'ici l'année notamment cuisinent avec
le service que renault met en place fin
septembre le pôle information agences de
l'it et de l'agglomération également
sera opérationnel
des très gros efforts sont entrepris par
l'agglomération d'ores et déjà 80 % des
arrêts de l'agglomération sont adaptés
sont aux normes personnes à mobilité
réduite
on a un petit peu plus de retard
concernant le matériel roulant
c'est bien le bus d'ores et déjà sept
lignes du réseau tibus sont accessibles
ces personnes d'ici 2015 la majorité des
lignes sera effectivement adapté énorme
en grande couronne d'agglomération de
saint quentin à l'un des réseaux les
plus adaptées pour louis voici pour
l'état des lieux mais la grande actu de
septembre dans les transports c'est
aussi la semaine de la mobilité qui se
déroulera du 16 au 22 septembre et là
encore la communauté d'agglomération
s'il devait d'être présente alors les
nouveautés c'est qu'on a augmenté le
partenariat avec les entreprises en leur
proposant un certain nombre d'outils et
les développer dans leur entreprise
les hawks ça peut être des animations
autour du vélo ou la marche à pied ça
peut être des colloques
le but c'est d'informer au mieux les
salariés de toutes les alternatives à la
voiture individuelle pour leur permettre
de se reporter sur un mode alternatif
que les économies de plus écologique
plus pratique quand même parfois quand
il s'agit des vélos pour des
déplacements quoi des actions
d'accompagnement ciblées qui petit à
petit semblent porter leurs fruits
on a de plus en plus d'entreprises qui
ne sollicitent de plus en plus de
salariés qui attendent ce rendez vous
est de plus en plus de salariés qui
passe au mode alternatif petit à petit
les changements de comportement se
mettre à plat en place et oui vu ce
train vélo marche véhicules et les
cliques aujourd'hui tous les moyens sont
à votre disposition pour bouger
autrement qu'en voiture
ici vous avez néanmoins besoin de
prendre votre véhicule
sachez que la communauté d'agglomération
a créé pour vous un site afin de vous
permettre de faire du covoiturage en
toute simplicité la mobilité à 50 en
ville et particulièrement les transports
en commun est un service public que l'on
veut de qualité est prioritaire sur
notre territoire à la fois bien sûr pour
les habitants de 50 amis nous mais aussi
pour le développement des entreprises
cde 7.25 plus de qualité on a non
seulement une redéfinition de la
desserte par les bus mais en même temps
dans toutes les gares de 50 à 1000 m des
travaux importants sont en cours
tout ce quotidien des transports en
commun sur 50 m libre
n'empêche pas en même temps de se battre
pour que les transports plus lourds
comme des infrastructures du grand paris
où la tangentielle ouest ne sert bien
notre territoire
et voici pour les transformer le
développement durable c'est également
des choix urbanistiques et
architecturaux ou encore une politique
de santé solidaire en faveur des
personnes en perte d'autonomie par
exemple que nous allons le voir dans nos
actus du mois
fidèle à sa mission de santé de
solidarité en faveur des personnes en
perte d'autonomie le groupement gironde
icap situe à magny les hameaux met en
place une semaine de l'autonomie du 3 au
5 octobre afin de rassembler des
professionnels de l'entreprise des
champs sanitaire des institutionnels des
universitaires des professionnels
sociaux médico-sociaux autour du thème
le temps du bien vivre dans la cité et
l'entreprise et pour bien vivre dans la
cité la communauté d'agglomération
aménagé cet été les abords de l'ufr des
sciences et de la santé ainsi qu'un
jardin imaginée par l'artiste nissim
mercado pour symboliser la connaissance
situé entre la faculté de médecine et le
lycée emilie breteuil
il se nomme joliment le parcours
d'hippocrate tout un programme
maisons à ossature bois chauffage au
bois système de récupération d'eau de
pluie la laquelle saint quentin vous
donne rendez vous le 29 septembre à 10
heures pour visiter une maison écolo
sans langue de bois nouveau cycle
technique de massage atelier de
réparation protection contre le vol
métiers et formations pour tout savoir
sur le vélo et sur sa pratique
rendez vous le 6 octobre à 14 heures à
la maison de l'environnement de saint
quentin en yvelines
à l'occasion d'une après midi festive
autour du vélo qui ne manquera pas de
vous remettre en selle un dossier que
vous pouvez retrouver dans lequel est
bien vivre du petit quentin du mois de
septembre avec l'article sur la
comédienne sophie broustal et le pari
fou de 3 saint-quentinoise qui se lance
dans le raid des amazones
mais pour l'heure on retrouve tous nos
rendez vous culturel du moment